Hallo, Guten Tag, mein Name ist Aydin. Ich bin hier als Synthetik und heute für Sie so ständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Gerne,
Könnten Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchen?
Gerne. Der Vorname ist Henry, also H, E, N, R, Y.
Der Nachnamen ist die Blume, B, L, Q, N, E.
Vielen Dank, Herr Blumen. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
Was sind Sie jetzt?
Am 6. April 1992.
Sie sind jetzt 19 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
Wie viel haben Sie?
70 kg.
Was für eine Schwalbe haben Sie?
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen eine starke Blutdurchfälle.
Seit 2 Tagen.
Wie oft sind Sie auf der Toilette?
Mindestens 5-6 Mal.
5-6 Mal pro Tag, ja.
Wie war die Blutdurchfälle?
Genau.
Gemächt.
Aber auch hell.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen.
Sie haben früher auch ähnliche Beschwäle gehabt?
Oder ist das erst einmal?
Ich habe das schon mal gehabt.
Vor 6 Monaten habe ich das 1 Tag angehabt.
Dann war das wieder weg.
Jetzt habe ich schon Angst, dass es was Schlimmes sein könnte.
Vor 6 Monaten haben Sie auch Blutdurchfälle gesehen?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe kampfartige Schmerzen.
Ich habe gestern Ibuprofen genommen, Parastarmol genommen.
Es hat ein bisschen geholfen, aber nicht viel.
Wie viele Tabletten haben Sie?
Und wie viele Milgramm?
Ein Ibup 400 zu Hause, die habe ich noch umliegen gehabt.
Ich habe 2 Tabletten Ibup und 1 Parastarmol genommen.
Ich habe 500 Milgramm.
Ich glaube, ich habe nicht nachgeschaut.
Ich habe das Bauchschmerzen gehabt.
Das war nachmittags, als ich von der Schule gekommen bin.
Und plötzlich kam der Durchfall.
Dann ging es mir ganz schlecht.
Das hat bis heute nicht mehr so gut gemacht.
Ich habe das auch nicht mehr gemacht.
Das war ganz schlecht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starker Schmerzen entspricht?
Also ich würde schon sagen, 6 bis 7 würde ich schon sagen.
Momentan haben Sie so stark Schmerzen?
Ja, es ist also, wenn, jetzt aktuell nicht, aber wenn gleich kommt,
dann kommt der Stuhlgang und dann tut es weh.
Okay, ja, verstehe.
Das zieht ziemlich stark.
Dann wird es ein bisschen weniger, aber es kommt und geht.
Es ist so kampfartig.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Aber ich glaube, Sie könnten bis Ende unserer Gespräche
diese Schmerzen aushalten.
Ich hoffe, wenn nicht, dann,
dann muss ich Ihnen bescheiden.
Okay, okay, bitte sagen Sie, kein Problem.
Herr Knume, wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Im Mittelbau oder rechtsseite, linksseite geh?
Also die ziehen so im Oberbau und dann links runter.
Links runter.
Also die fangen aber oben an.
Die ziehen Sie nach links unten in den Unterbauch ein.
Und das ist so kampfartig, muss man sagen.
Sonst, wenn sich da etwas zusammenschnüren würde.
Okay.
Ich trage die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus in anderen Körperregionen?
Nee.
Also es ist nur der Bauch betroffen.
Okay, okay.
Herr Knume, haben Sie eine Vermutung,
woran das liegen könnte?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich mache Sport.
Ich bin eigentlich recht gesund, muss man sagen.
Ich habe noch nie ernsthaft Erkrankungen gehabt.
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Also es ist auch nichts in den letzten Tagen passiert.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, war dieses Bechwerde lindert oder verstärkt?
Nee.
Okay.
Herr Knume, hat Sie in den letzten Zeiten eine Reise gehabt?
Haben Sie in den letzten Zeiten eine Reise gehabt?
Nee, habe ich auch schon überlegt, aber nein, das ist schon lange her.
Es war im Sommer gewesen.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas überlegt?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Haben Sie etwas erbrochen?
Nein.
Für Sie sich viel brennt?
Aktuell nicht, nein.
Nicht wirklich.
Okay.
Jetzt wie fühlen Sie sich?
Zum Beispiel ist das Ihnen schwarz voll augen?
Also ich fühle mich sehr schwach.
Ich könnte mich jetzt wieder hinlegen.
Und ich habe Angst vor dem nächsten Stuhlgang.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben sich nicht.
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt, aber als ich aus dem Auto gerade ausgestiegen bin,
bin ich ein bisschen jünger, zügiger gegangen.
Da war mir schon ein bisschen schwindelig, tatsächlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Ein bisschen, ich glaube schon, ja.
Jetzt momentan.
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Okay.
Ich habe aber nicht kontrolliert.
Ich möchte jetzt unser Gespräch kurz unterbrechen.
Um Ihre Vital parameter kontrollieren zu können.
Ich werde Ihren Zawaustoffsetigung,
Ihre Herzfrequenz und Blutdruck messen.
Dann könne ich mich wieder unter Gespräch weiterführen.
Gerne, Gerne, vielen Dank.
Okay.
Ich habe alle Schema, ich glaube, die Petition ist stabil.
Herr Blümann, ich werde ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer allgemeinen Zustand stellen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe jetzt nichts bemerkt.
Haben Sie in der Lessenseiten ab oder zu genommen?
Nee, ich wiege eigentlich immer so um die 70 Kilo, manchmal 69, manchmal 68.
Also kommt immer darauf an, wie viel Sport ich mache.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhl, beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, habe ich nicht bemerkt. Nein.
Haben Sie im Stuhl auch Schlein benenkt?
Ich habe mich nicht nachgeschaut.
Was ist Durchfall? Blutig?
Blutig, Durchfall.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
In der Regel nicht, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwärsche Erkrankungen herbekommen?
Ich meine Schilderysenprobleme, Zuckerkrankheit?
Nichts bekannt.
Also ich habe vor zwei Jahren einen Checkup bei meinem Arzt machen lassen,
aber auch alles unhoffällig gewesen.
Forstweiheirn, varelles Neuerhörnung.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie irgendwärsche Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Herr Bullum?
Ich meine gegen Corona und auch Erfolgserkrankungen?
Ja.
Also ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Das ist auch vor zwei Jahren bei meinem Hausarzt,
beim Checkup kontrolliert worden.
Und danach bin ich halt noch gegen Corona, also gegen Covid geimpft.
Okay.
Sonst habe ich alle alle Impfungen,
die ich jetzt in der Regel habe.
Sonst habe ich alle alle Impfungen.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendeinwärsche Allergen bekannt?
Nicht das Wüste, nein.
Okay.
Herr Bullum, leiden Sie unter Stress?
Zum Beispiel, haben Sie etwas, was Sie sehr belasten?
Also der übliche Stress eigentlich bin ich sehr entspannt,
muss ich sagen, aber der übliche Stress, den ich habe in der Schule,
sonst alles okay.
Sie sind Lehrer, ja?
Genau.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Bullum?
Nein.
Früher haben Sie geraut, oder?
Nein, noch nie.
Sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, manchmal.
Wenn Freunde da sind oder so, es ist aber selten.
Ich bin jetzt nicht der regelmäßige Trinker.
Also ab und zu machen oder wenn wir draußen sind.
Zum Beispiel einmal pro Woche oder nur Wochenende?
Ich würde sagen alle zwei Wochen vielleicht ein bisschen,
wenn wir draußen sind oder wenn Gäste da sind.
Okay.
War auch nicht viel, ne?
Nicht viel.
Ich nehme keinen Drogen ein.
Sehe ich aus wie ein Drogen, als wenn ich Drogen einnehme?
Nein, eigentlich, ich denke eher nicht.
Aber das ist eine Routine Frage und medizinische Frage.
Okay.
Verstanden.
Okay, verstanden.
Ich glaube, Sie treiben Sport, ja?
Ja, ja, ich gehe regelmäßig laufen.
Regelmäßig laufen.
Also alle drei Tage gehe ich laufen und versuche, mich auch fit zu halten.
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay.
Wir kommen fast zu Ende.
Ich würde jetzt zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nee, also, sie haben meinen Vater Bluthochdruck.
Und meine Mutter hat eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Ansonsten sind mir keine Erkrankungen bekannt, tatsächlich.
Schilddrüsenunterfunktion, okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist auch gesund, ja.
Also, weil ich weiß, ja.
Okay.
Nein, nein.
Ich bin ledig.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich kontrolliere kurz.
Haben Sie denn schon, was ich haben könnte?
Also, muss ich heute hier bleiben?
Weil ich fühle mich wirklich schwach.
Ich würde gerne, dass es einmal kontinuiert wird.
Ja.
Herr Blüm, meine Meinung nach, sie sollten hier bleiben im Krankenhaus.
Ich werde sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen und dann brauche ich ein paar Untersuchungen.
Nach der Untersuchung können wir genau sprechen,
aber ich glaube jetzt, sie sollten hier bleiben.
Ich glaube, sie haben eine vielleicht chronische Darmerkrankung.
Ja, das heißt, dass es ein chronisch und entsündig Darmerkrankung sein kann.
Aber wie ich gesagt habe, ich werde sie jetzt untersuchen und wir müssen das feststellen.
Und dann kann ich Ihnen sagen, was Sie genau haben.
Kann das auch etwas Schlimmes sein?
Also, ich habe gehört, dass mal der Vater von einem Kollegen von mir auch
Darmkrebs gehabt hat und der auch daran verstorben muss.
Deswegen bin ich schon sehr besorgt.
Das ist keine Krebserkrankung.
Deswegen, Sie sollten nicht an die Schlimmsten nicht denken.
Aber das kann auch eine ernsthafte Krankheit sein.
Sie müssen unbedingt behandelt werden, wenn mein Verdastiatnose richtig ist.
Aber das kann einfach eine Infektionskrankheit auch sein.
Nach der Untersuchung, nach der Stuhl-Untersuchung können wir das auch ausschließen.
Ja, in diesem Fall. Die Behandlung ist einfacher.
Aber meine Verdastiatnose ist anders eigentlich.
Eine chronisch entsündige Darmerkrankung denke ich.
Okay, okay.
Okay, vielleicht muss ich denn länger jetzt im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Muss ich meinem Arbeit hier Bescheid sagen?
Eigentlich, ich kann jetzt das nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich brauche diese Untersuchung und ihre Blutwerte sind wichtig.
Ich werde den Bau ultra-schall durchführen.
Und dann können wir etwas genauer sprechen.
Okay, vielen Dank, dass Sie mich so gut aufgeklärt haben.
Dankeschön.
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihr Geduld.
Jetzt bitte eine Frage.
Gibt es jemanden in Ihrer Umgebung der Enche Bescheide hat?
Jetzt aktuell, meinen Sie?
Jetzt aktuell, ja.
Also nicht bekannt, nein.
Okay, danke.
Ich denke, hat Sie gute Fragen gestartet?
Sie hat mich gut aufgeklärt, nicht?
Danke.
Mein Fazit ist, ich bin Patient.
Ich weiß nicht, Sie sind jetzt.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Können wir anfangen, als als Geist?
Gerne.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen unsere neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Herr Henry Buluma ist 90 Jahre alt.
Wie alt?
30 Jahre alt.
Ich habe die Geburtstatung gesehen.
Er ist 1,75 m groß.
Er ist 20 kg schwer.
Er ist ein Patient.
Er ist 5 Jahre alt.
Er ist ein
».
Momentan, momentan, heute gestern haben die Patienten gegen diese Schmerzen 2 mal 400 mg Ibuprofen und 1 mal 500 mg Paracetamol einen Genom.
Die Medikamente haben ein reine Geholfen. Fiba nausea, Fiba nausea wurden fernleinet. Die Patienten klackte über 50 Tachikardi und schivachgefühlen.
Die Reskulche vegetative anamnese sei unaufwendig. Die Patienten habe keine Kronische oder wichtige Porerkrankung.
Bei ihm sei keine Operation durchgeführt worden. Er nehme keine Medikamente regelmäßig ein. Er sei vollständig geimpft. Bei ihm sei keine Allergie bekannt.
Der Patient konsumiert weder Nikotin noch Drogen. Er trinkt sehr selten Alkohol und er gehe regelmäßig alle 3 Tage laufen. Er ist sehr sportlich aktiv.
Die Familien anamnese ergab eine arterielle Hypertonie beinfacht. Eine Schilddürre ist unter Funktion hypotiroease by the emote.
Der Patient habe eine Gesundeschwester. Er sei ledig und habe keine Kinder. Er sei Lehrer von Beruf.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine chronische insündliche Darmerkrankung hin.
Das kann ein Koalites ulcerosa oder Morbus Crohn sein. Aber mit blutiger Durstfall und hematöche, ja mit blutiger Durstfall hematöche ist ja unbauchschmerzen.
Denken, dass es eine Koalites ulcerosa ist. Der Patient hat keine andere Beziehung. Keine andere Symptome für eine Morbus Crohn.
Der Patient hat keine Nachschweiß.
Er hat keine Gewichtverlust. Aber nach der Koalites ulcerosa haben Sie gesagt, dass der Patient den Patienten körperlich untersucht.
Der Patient hat eine Abwehrspannung im Bauch. Er hat keine akutten Abdomen. Aber ich würde das auch kontrollieren.
Was haben Sie bei der Koalites ulcerosa nicht vergessen?
Ich kann gleich kontrollieren, ob der Patient wirklich einen blutigen Stuhl hat.
Das kann ich auch ein Stuhlprobe entnehmen.
Sie können aber auch Tasten, ob er zum Beispiel einen Tumor hat.
Manchmal sind die Patienten ja sehr besorgt, wenn ein bisschen Blut im Stuhl ist. Es ist doch nicht so viel.
Es war letztendlich nur eine Hemeroide oder eine Analfissur, die auch mal Schmerzen bereiten kann.
Es kommt immer so drauf an, wie die Patienten das darstellen.
Aber Sie haben schon recht, der Verdacht einer chronischen, entzündlichen Damerkrankung ist sehr nah.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Beim Labor werde ich Blutbildentzündungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Dann werde ich eine Abdomenssonografie durchführen.
Vielleicht kann ich feststellen, ob eine Darmband-Fertigung vorliegt.
Oder eine freie Flüssigkeit.
Sie können nachschauen, ob er einen Ilios hat.
Es kann auch sein, ob er einen Toxicis-Megacolon hat.
Das ist eher ein akuten Abdomen.
Das fällt mir nicht ein.
Ist der Darmband sehr erweitert?
Ja.
Das ist eher ein akuten Abdomen.
Ultrisch halt kann man das nicht so oft sehen.
Ich habe auch noch ein paar Beispiele.
Hat er noch andere Beschwerden geäußert?
Er hat gesagt, dass er sehr gesund ist.
Er hat eine Erdtisch-Karlinie.
Sie können gleich noch mal machen.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass er Schmerzen hat, die vom Oberbach runterziehen.
Sie haben gefragt, ob das nach dem Stuhlgang besser ist.
Sie wissen, wie man das nennt.
Manchmal beschreiben die Patienten auch, die haben Angst vom Stuhlgang.
Sie haben gesagt, sie machen Ultrischal.
Sie nehmen die Patienten sicherlich auf?
Nein, ich würde die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich werde die Patienten über die wenigen Flüssigkeit zuvor anfangen.
Ich werde natürlich die Blutbild kontrollieren, ob die Patient Anime hat.
Immerhin sollten wir Flüssigkeit zuvor.
Was machen Sie dann, wenn alles stabil ist?
Er hat ein bisschen Entzündungszeichen, ein bisschen CHP, ein bisschen BSG.
Er hat auch ein bisschen leuker Zytose, eine amineleichte, 11 oder 10.
Sie würden den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, mit dem Verdacht einer chronischen
entzündlichen Damerkrankung.
Aber wenn der Patient stabil wäre, können wir auch ambulant behandeln.
Er beschreibt schon, dass er 5-6 Mal am Tag blutige Stuhlgang hat.
Er hat die Stuhlgangsschritte, die er aufnehmen kann.
Wenn er jetzt einmal hier ist, sollten wir den Patienten aufnehmen und ihn mit einer Diagnose nach Hause lassen.
Welche diagnostischen Schritte außer einem Ultrischal, außer Laborwerten,
machen Sie noch, wenn Sie den Verdacht auf eine chronische entzündliche Damerkrankung haben?
Dafür brauchen wir ein Vorbereitungszeit.
Der Patient sollte Apfiamitil benutzen.
Dabei muss der Darm leer sein, damit wir besser die Darmmucosa beurteilen können.
Das ist eine sehr aktuelle Methode.
Sie sollten trotzdem dran denken, dass Sie trotzdem Stuhlproben mitnehmen.
Sie können auch noch mal kalt Prokretin, Laktopherin nachbestimmen.
Man kann auch Kontrast-Einlauf machen.
Man kann auch sehen, ob die Haustrierung des Dickdarms ist.
Der Dickdarm hat ja so Falten.
Man kann auch sehen, ob die Haustrierung noch da ist.
Manchmal kann man einen sehr schlimmen Verlauf, einen Fahrradschlauch,
das ist dann das Colon.
Man sollte eine Darmspiegelung machen, um zu schauen, ob da alles Norden ist.
Bei der Darmspiegelung soll man nur eine Darmspiegelung schauen.
Wie würden Sie den Patienten behandeln, wenn ich fragen darf?
Schmerz-Jerapie ist eigentlich ganz normale Schmerz. Sie können ihm einfach Novalgin zum Beispiel
geben oder so etwas in der Art. Ich würde jetzt kein Ibuprofen oder so etwas geben. NSRR sind nicht so der,
NSRR können sogar, wenn man zu viel davon nimmt, laut den Angaben auch eine chronische
Darmenentzündung verursachen, rein theoretisch. Aber ich würde eher so Novalgin oder so etwas geben.
Tatsächlich ja oder Parz de Moll. Wichtig ist hier aber tatsächlich die Glucocortico-Glucococortico-Glucococortico-Therapie.
Natürlich also Cortisonentherapie machen. Und dann muss man im Verlauf schauen, wie das anspricht
gegebenenfalls, wie Sie sich umsachten, immunsupressiver Azatiprin fällt mir jetzt ein, zum Beispiel
und dengleichen, würden Sie das denn die Cortisonentherapie als Tablette geben oder würden Sie das
intravenös geben oder würden Sie das rektal geben? Wie würden Sie das machen? Vielleicht in diesem
Fall können wir mit intravenöse Therapien anfangen, weil wir können wegen der Durchfühlung
resoriert werden. Ja, also tatsächlich ist es so, dass man die Cortisonentherapie intravenös macht,
stationär, je nachdem wo in der Endeskopie, wo das Problem sitzt, also ob das jetzt ein Rectum ist,
im Sigma ist oder im Coulom Descendis ist, zum Beispiel, kann man auch eine lokale Cortison-Schaum-Therapie
oder Zefchentherapie machen, geht auch. Genau, kann man auch stationär machen, weil es dann
direkt vor Ort wirkt. Es gibt tatsächlich Medikament, die man mit Rectalschaum, zum Beispiel
Bude Zenut oder sowas nur, man kann auch sogar mehr Salat ziehen, gibt es auch, dass man geben kann.
Diese Medikamente kann man alle machen natürlich, aber dazu muss man erst eine Diagnose stellen
und Sie haben das alles wunderbar gemacht, muss man sagen. Würden Sie denn sagen,
dieser Patient hat einen normalen Verlauf, mittelschweren Verlauf, leichten Verlauf,
sehr schweren Verlauf oder sogar vielleicht lebensgefährlich in den Lauf?
Ja, der Patient ist 30 Jahre alt und vielleicht die Krankheit fange jetzt ein und das kann auch,
ja meine Meinung nach, kann es ein schwerer Verlauf sein. Die Beschwerden haben mit
Blutung und starken Diären angefangen, aber ich habe nicht so viel Idee, das ist nur eine Meinung.
Aber er hat das schon mal gehabt, haben Sie erzählt, oder? Ja, früher hat er einen Mann gehabt.
Das Problem schon mal gehabt, das heißt er hat wahrscheinlich das Problem schon länger
und wird jetzt erst richtig symptomatisch dadurch, muss wahrscheinlich jetzt auch
eine Therapie bekommen. Ich gehe jetzt nicht weiter auf die Therapiemöglichkeiten ein,
das ist zu speziell. Man kann natürlich auch Biologicals nehmen, man kann intravenöse,
Antikörpertherapien, also was machen, aber das wird jetzt in Rahmen springen.
Sie haben alles richtig gemacht, ich finde sie an was auch sehr gut dargestellt.
Also ich habe jetzt nichts zu beanstanden, ehrlich gesagt. Wunderbar, Klasse.
Ich habe sie sehr gut verstanden und mein Lob sehr gut. Ja, vielen Dank.